ça y est le drapeau polonais flotte dans
le port de Briard à quai le long du
canal les bateaux des mariniers en
provenance direct de cracovi des
embarcations polonaises traditionnelles
plus habitué aux zoau nationale de la
Vistule qu'à celle des cours d'eau du
Loiré alors forcément ça ne passe pas
inaperçu auprès des
promeneurs qu'est-ce qui me plaît ben
c'est le le côté bois le côté rustique
le côté nature j'admire ces gens-là
parmi ces gens-là Eva et Sigmund à bord
de leur embarcation une réplique d'un
transporteur de marchandise du 15e
siècle ils sont arrivés aussi samedi
après-midi à Briard pour cela comme
leurs autres collègues mariniers ils
auront parcouru près de 3000 km de
navigation sur les fleus et Canau de
Pologne d'Allemagne des Pays-Bas puis de
Belgique et enfin de France au total 4
mois de vie à bord par tous les temps
jour et nuit pour une plus grande
recherche
nous avons choisi ce mode de vie afin de
pouvoir expérimenter la façon dont ça se
passait au 15e siècle quand les gens
avaient à utiliser ce type d'embarcation
pour leur travail il vivait à bord
connaître cet aspect des choses c'était
pour nous un défi à
relever un exploit qui va maintenant
changer totalement de physionomie faute
de tir
les bateaux seront chargés mercredi sur
des camions direction Orléan où ils
retrouveront leur élément naturels le
public en plus à l'occasion du Festival
de Loire